- Um, Luke.
Okay, Luke has been asking this question
at least ten times in the chat.
Luke, I'm hearing you.
There's a ton of questions,
we're going to get it.
This is for you Luke, okay.
Luke says I'm a young entrepreneur
and people keep telling me
or giving me the feeling
that I won't be successful.
What advice do you have?
- Wow, Luke.
Actually I'll say one
thing that blew me away,
I went on the floor and
we did loads of mentoring,
I met a 14 year old entrepreneur
on a second business idea.
I loved it, it blew me away.
God.
So Luke, I don't know what age you are
but there is so many people
and maybe this is a little bit agist
but particularly some older people
who probably will tell you the reasons
why it's not such a good idea.
But if you believe in it
and then do everything we talked
about in previous programs,
test your idea, test
drive it, road test it,
you can road test it with your friends,
you can road test it on social,
and you can create a following,
and that will give you
the energy and positivity
to know that your idea's going to land.
But how do you know if an idea
is not going to land if you don't try it.
And back to that example,
if you don't try it,
you know failure is
actually, not trying it.
The fear of failure actually creates it,
it's almost like a cancer,
you fail to try it,
then you've let us all down
because you could've done it.
I'll tell you, Evan will tell you today,
if you have an idea, if you back yourself,
you're halfway there.
And what is brilliant
and what I love doing more than anything
is defying the cynics.
Loads of people could
be cynical or jealous.
People might be jealous
that you've had that idea,
and you're going to make
your idea come to reality.
And you're going to make
your dreams come true.
But back yourself, and I...
Whatever happens, you
know, and it's amazing,
you never know what twists and turns
life's got in front of you.
So I'll give you an example,
when I left graduate school,
and it was before the internet,
so I wrote, one of my buddies,
I'll give you an example,
a real good buddy called
Paul Smith, great guy,
he wrote 240 companies,
240 companies.
And he only got a handful of replies,
all of those turned him down,
he didn't even get an interview.
But he kept on going and just,
can you imagine how demoralizing.
I got turned down by so many
companies for graduate school.
I even got turned down,
you know I applied to all these
great companies at the top
called Unilever, and all these great, PNG,
and they turned me down.
So one of the things, funny thing is,
Evan, in those days you kind
of did these placements.
I did a four year course
and I did kind of two,
they call it sandwich course,
a placement of the company.
And the company that I
did a placement at, BP,
I thought I was a shoe-in for the job,
I went for the job, and I got turned down!
How does that work?
But you just got to pick yourself up
what what I would say,
there's a few things,
in that sort of scenario,
one of the things that I
ask for which is so powerful
that I don't think very
few people ask for,
is a magic word called feedback.
If people turn you down,
whether it's for an audition
if you want to be an actor,
whether it's a business
person, you did a pitch,
or if you're going to
lay the stage company,
if you're going to raise money
and you do a pitch to your family,
why they backed you and
why they turned you down.
If you ask for feedback,
it is mind-blowing
how you can improve your
business, your product,
your whole sales pitch, your web site,
your social experience.
So I think, bottom line Luke,
is back yourself, defy
the cynics, try your idea,
and constantly have
those social antenna on,
to say how can I constantly
improve and create my product,
and my idea to make it
land and make it big.
- I love it.
And Luke is loving that
we picked his question,
so he's happy in the chat.
Luke, I would say,
I would say, one, back to our
initial comment at the top,
about the environment,
the environment matters.
I would start surrounding myself with
young entrepreneurs who are
off trying to do something.
And if you don't have any young
entrepreneurs that you know,
go to meetups, go to events,
try to connect with them.
If you still can't find them,
then read articles, watch videos,
learn from people who are already doing it
so that you know that if it's possible.
I think Mark Zuckerberg's
big success made it possible
for a lot of young
entrepreneurs to realize
hey if he can do it, I can do it too,
I'm going to bet on myself.
And then the second thing
I would think about is
the people who are giving you the advice,
and maybe because they're jealous,
and maybe because they love you.
Maybe mom and dad love you
and they just don't want to see you fail.
They're not trying to hurt you,
they think they're trying to help you.
I would look at, have the people
who are giving you this
advice done it before?
Have they done it themselves?
If they haven't, then they may
not be in the best position,
like the people who are hating on you,
if they haven't done it themselves,
they haven't taken a chance themselves,
maybe they're not the best people
to kind of be giving you that advice.
So I wouldn't pay
attention to them, right?
Find out, seek out the mentors
who you can learn from.